welcome back here with us now is a man
who survived the shooting from the front
row of the VIP section of that fateful
Las Vegas concert back in October Brian
Claypool joins us now
he's also an attorney assisting dozens
of survivors and victims families and
their search for answers Brian to be
back here in Las Vegas the second time
have been here since the shooting I
thought by this time I'd have more
answers to report on but every time we
get a new piece of information it seems
to raise another question what is the
burning question in your mind now that
we hear that there may be charges more
charges in this case well Laura thanks
for having me by the way and and to let
you know this is my first day back in
Las Vegas since being a survivor of the
shooting and I had a meeting out here
today on the Vegas shooting case and I
got to tell you when I got off the plane
I was walking toward the exit of the
airport and I saw the Mandalay Bay right
out the window and I had two feelings
that came to me I had anxiety and then
the second feeling was anger and I speak
for all those survivors out there and
all those family members who lost loved
ones in this shooting here's what we
want to know what we want to know why
the Las Vegas metropolitan Police
Department why the FBI in concert with
the MGM and Mandalay Bay our scripting a
narrative that this is just a lone wolf
shooting that this is just some 64 year
old or however all this dude was patek
some depressed guy that wanted to do
mass shooting we know for a fact that
that that that's likely not to be the
case but you hit the nail on the head
earlier greed in this shooting eclipses
public public safety and we want answers
why the MGM and Mandalay Bay did not
better prepare for this mass shooting
because remember you have you talked
about this before in May of this year of
last year there was a credible report of
a potential Isis attack in Vegas so this
was no you know no fictional event that
was going to happen and I know we're
gonna find out in discovery in this case
that the Metropolitan PD and sheriff
Lombardo met with the
casinos to make sure they had some kind
of plans in place to prevent a mass
shooting you know a friend of mine
messaged me when he knew I was doing
this segment who was also there that
night and he said you can confirm this
that when finally they allowed people to
leave the vicinity the ones who didn't
already get out they didn't they didn't
check anyone who was leaving so the
police actually didn't there was no
check of you know sometimes people blend
in with a crowd obviously this guy was
on the you know multiple floors up but
even that was odd here and we were
almost at a time largest final thoughts
from you yeah Laurel Arlen and we just
tell you this I was in the manual I was
in the Mandalay Bay I stayed there I was
on the 26th floor let me tell you how
bad the security was the day after the
shooting I finally went to try to get
back in my room and there was finally a
security guard there he didn't even ask
me for any ID I just went right up to my
room this is now I'm sorry have to cut
you off but unbelievable story well can
I stay on this we're not letting it go